JUDGE JEANINE: THE RACE FOR A
VACCINE INTENSIFIES AS SOME
STATES GRADUALLY BEGIN TO
RE-OPEN.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE INFECTED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE WHITE
HOUSE EFFORTS AND THE RESPONSE
COORDINATOR, DR. DEBORAH BIRX.
I WANT TO START AT THE
BEGINNING.
IN THE BEGINNING IT WAS
SUGGESTED THE MORTALITY RATE
WOULD BE 5% AND THE NUMBERS ARE
SO MUCH HIGHER THAN WHAT WE
THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE.
BUT THE CDC NEVER USED THE THE
TEST BASE TO COUPLE WITH A
LETHALITY BASIS.
THEY DIDN’T USE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE EXPOSED TO
ACCURATELY CONSIDER THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AFFECTED BY COVID.
ISN’T THAT A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FROM HOW THE CDC EVALUATED THE
FLU?
NOW THAT WE TEST PEOPLE WE KNOW
THE RATE IS SO MUCH LOWER.
>> I THINK WE ARE LEARNING EVERY
DAY ABOUT THE VIRUS AND HOW IT
INTERACTS WITH US AS HUMAN
HOSTS.
THAT’S IMPORTANT TO CONSTANTLY
BE TRY AGE YOU -- USING DATA.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT GET
INFECTED THAT THE SYMPTOMS ARE
SO LOW GRADE THEY DON’T EVEN
KNOW THEY ARE INFECTED.
WE ARE BEGINNING TO SEE THAT
WITH THE NEW YORK STUDIES WITH
THE ANTIBODY STUDIES.
IN EVERY OTHER COUNTRY BEFORE
THEY HAD THE ANTIBODY TESTS, ALL
THEY COULD SEE WERE CASE THAT
SHOWED UP WITH SERIOUS SYMPTOMS.
SO THINGS ARE CHANGING ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE CDC IS
MANDATING THAT DEATHS SUSPECTED
AS COVID BE ATTRIBUTED TO COVID.
IF SOMEONE IS IN THE HOSPITAL
DYING OF CANCER OR HAS A HEART
PROBLEM.
IF YOU HAVE DOCTORS OR NURSES
WEARING THE SAME PPE EQUIPMENT
WHO MAY BE TRANSFERRING COVID ON
THE SKIN OR A NASAL PASSAGE
ABOUT IT ISN’T IN THE BLOOD,
ISN’T IT UNFAIR TO SUGGEST THOSE
DEATHS THAT AREN’T ACTUALLY
CAUSED BY COVID ARE ATTRIBUTABLE
TO COVID IF COVID IS ANYWHERE IN
THE SYMPTOMS OF THE DECEASED.
>> THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX VIRUS.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR IT’S
HIGHLY TRANSMISSIBLE AND HIGHLY
INFECTIOUS.
YOU HAVE CO-MORBIDITIES, HEART
DISEASE.
DIABETES.
ASTHMA, CANCER.
IF YOU ARE IMMUNOSUPPRESSED.
THAT MAKES YOU US SEPTEMBERIBLE
ANOTHER COURSE.
I BELIEVE MANY OF THE CASES WE
ARE SEEING IN THE HOSPITAL HAVE
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS, BUT
THOSE PREEXISTING CONDITIONS ARE
RESULTING IN THEM HAVING A MUCH
MORE SERIOUS COURSE WHEN THEY
ARE INFECTED WITH THIS VIRUS.
JUDGE JEANINE: WOULD YOU AGREE
IT WAS INITIALLY THOUGHT THIS
WAS A RESPIRATORY ILLNESS THAT
PRIMARILY AFFECTED THE
RESPIRATORY SYSTEM.
OUT OF THE GATE WE STARTED
TALKING ABOUT VENTILATORS.
BUT AS WE WENT ALONG WE REALIZE
IT AFFECTS THE BLOOD AND THE
IMMUNE SYSTEM AND THE KIDNEYS.
SO THE THINKING IN THE BEGINNING
THAT THIS NEEDED TO BE HANDLED
WITH VENTILATORS AND FINDING 80
TO 90% OF PEOPLE WHO WENT ON
VENTILATORS ENDED UP DYING.
DID WE APPROACH THIS WITH THE
SAME METHODOLOGY?
DID WE INTUBATE TOO SOON?
>> THE DOCTORS AND NURSES ON THE
FRONT LINE, THEY ARE WATCHING
EVERY PATIENT CLOSELY.
THEY ARE WATCHING FOR WHAT WE
CALL THE OXYGEN LEVEL IN THE
BLOOD TO INSURE.
THAT’S WHAT YOU NEED FOR YOUR
BRAIN AND HEART AND KIDNEYS TO
KEEP FUNCTIONING.
IF YOUR OXYGEN LEVEL FALLS TOO
LOW AND CANNOT BE KEPT UP WITH
WHAT WE CALL NASAL CAN YOU LAS
OR REBREATHING OXYGEN MASKS, IF
YOU CAN’T GET ENOUGH OXYGEN FROM
THAT, THEN THEY WILL INTUBATE
THE PATIENT.
THAT EARLY REPORT HAS BEEN
REVISED THAT TALKED ABOUT THE
HIGHER MORTALITY.
IT’S VARIABLE BY AGE AND LENGTH
OF TIME IN THE HOSPITAL.
WE ARE FIRING YOUNGER PEOPLE OF
75 TO 80% SURVIVAL ON
VENTILATORS.
YOU CAN’T LOOK AT JUST ONE
HOSPITAL.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL THE
INFORMATION.
BUT VENTILATORS SAVED A LOT OF
PEOPLE’S LIVES BECAUSE THEY WERE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING OXYGEN
INTO THEIR BLOOD.
JUDGE JEANINE: FINALLY, DOCTOR,
POINT BE A BETTER IDEA TO HAVE
THOSE LOW-RISK INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NOW BEING ISOLATED EVEN IF
THEY ARE INFECTED, ISN’T IT A
BETTER IDEA TO ALLOW THEM TO GO
OUT AND AT LEAST START TO
DEVELOP THE HERD IMMUNITY THAT
WE NEED?
BECAUSE THEY ARE ONLY GOING TO
DEVELOP THE DISEASE IN A VERY
MILD WAY.
AND ISN’T THE HERD IMMUNITY
ESSENTIAL TO ULTIMATELY GETTING
RID OF THIS VIRUS UNTIL AT THE
VERY LEAST WE GET A VACCINE?
>> WELL, THE MOST IMPORTANT WAY
TO GET RID OF THIS VIRUS IS SOME
GET A VACCINE AS YOU DESCRIBED.
WE ALWAYS USED THE TERM HERD
IMMUNITY WHEN IT COMES TO
VACCINATION.
NO ONE WOULD USE THAT TERM IN
GENERAL IN DISCUSSING A PANDEMIC
AND LETTING A AND DEJ RUN OUT
WITH THIS LEVEL OF MORTALITY
THAT WE SEE WITH CO-MORBIDITIES.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER IN AMERICA
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE,
EVEN YOUNG PEOPLE WITH DIABETES
AND ASTHMA AND HYPERTENSION.
PROTECTING THEM BECOMES CRITICAL
BECAUSE THEY COULD HAVE A
DIFFICULT COURSE.
IF WE KNEW EVERYBODY WHO WOULD
DO WELL IMMEDIATELY YOU COULD
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
BUT WE DON’T KNOW WHO HAS
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS WHEN WE
SEE THEM ON THE STREET.
THAT’S WHY THE PRESIDENT MADE IT
CLEAR THAT IN OPENING UP AMERICA
AGAIN, THERE ARE CLEAR CRITERIA
AND PHASES EVERY STATE NEEDS TO
CONSIDER.
IN THE BOTTOM LINE OF ALL OF
THIS IS EVERY INDIVIDUAL STILL
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY OF WASHING
THEIR HANDS, NOT TOUCHING THEIR
FACE.
WHEN THEY CAN’T SOCIAL DISTANCE,
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE WEARING A
MASK.
YOU WEAR A MASK TO PROTECT THE
OTHER PERSON.
WHEN YOU MEET THEM ON THE STREET
YOU DON’T KNOW IF THEY HAVE A
PREEXISTING CONDITION AND MAY BE
SUSCEPTIBLE WITH A DIFFICULT
COURSE WITH THIS VIRUS.
THERE ARE 66, 67,000 PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SUCCUMBED TO THIS VIRUS IN
7 WEEKS.
WHEN WE’LL COMPARE IT TO THE
FLU, FLU MAY HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
MORTALITY, ABOUT IT MANY OVER
WEEKS AND MONTHS.